the debate in Washington about funding
president Trump's border wall comes amid
growing questions about a barriers
effectiveness in the fight against drug
trafficking since 1990 Border Patrol
agents have discovered at least 230
cross-border tunnels running from Mexico
into California and Arizona they have
seized loads of cocaine methamphetamines
and marijuana inside them Mireya
Villarreal went below ground with agents
in Nogales Arizona to see how they're
dealing with the threat Border Patrol
agents not only have to protect what's
above the border around first but also
what lies beneath this is already in
place built by the cities to drain water
infrastructure that smugglers are taking
advantage of what they're building is
tapping into this new building an
illicit tunnel the Deputy patrol agent
in charge in Nogales
Kevin Hecht took us through the tunnels
used to Train agents to spot breaches
made by smugglers sometimes we got to
strip down because it's so tight gun
belt off and gun in hand on a flashlight
in the other very very simple earlier
this month the Mexican Federal Police
discovered this tunnel that accessed the
sewer system that flows into the United
States and last month the Border Patrol
sealed this unfinished tunnel that
crossed into Arizona these tunnels are
about drugs oh yes for most parts Peck
says smugglers ongoing use of these
makes tunnel training essential in
training you'll go in this pipe and
you'll be like okay I'm above-ground and
qualify for everything is fine okay
let's put you someone under some earth
and see how you react how do you not
then get that claustrophobic feeling
like how do you get them past that can
so either you're gonna do it or you're
not and we figure out who that is so
they're smuggling contraband into these
pipes so we need to make that stop so
it's the point is to find those
remediate the tunnel fill the concrete
and then move on to the next pipe for
CBS this morning
Mireya Villarreal Nogales Arizona